enterrer la sécurité sociale étudiante
jusqu'ici elle était gérée en france par
les mutuelles étudiantes qui étaient
chargés de les affiliés à la sécurité
sociale
désormais tous les étudiants dépendront
du régime général
comme c'était le cas durant leur
scolarité jusqu'au lycée pas de raison
de paniquer il n'y aura aucune démarche
à faire concernant les nouveaux
étudiants pour la rentrée 2010 8
rien ne change il faudra simplement
qu'ils s'assurent que leurs coordonnées
personnelles sont bien à jour
éventuellement créer un compte ameli si
ça n'est pas déjà fait et puis donc
bien bien s'assurer que ils mettent leur
carte vitale à jour il reste sur le
compte des parents et les bascules se
feront en cours d'année automatiquement
les étudiants déjà inscrits dans une
mutuelle étudiants pour rien ne change
ils n'auront pas à verser la cotisation
non plus ils sont exemptes et la bascule
se fera pour eux l'année prochaine à la
rentrée 2010 9 l'ancien cotisation
annuelle à la sécurité sociale d'un
montant de 217 euros est supprimé c'est
une contribution obligatoire unique de
90 euros qui la remplace elle est
destinée à financer la vie du campus et
les boursiers en seront exonérés
j'étais directement affiliée à ma
sécurité sociale le gîte l année
dernière donc ça change rien pour moi
pour moi c'était moins cher je trouve
que c'est que du positif
à la rentrée 2010 9 l'ancien système
aura entièrement disparu les mutualisent
étudiante elle ne se seront pas
totalement leurs activités puisqu'elle
continuerons de proposer des
complémentaires santé aux étudiants qui
souhaiteront y adhérer